can you consider me a 100 million dollar
ceo i get asked all the time what does a
day look like as a 100 million dollar
ceo the night before is actually where
my day starts and so before i go into
the next day my days actually planned
out to the minute in terms of what
projects am i going to do and i actually
placed those on my calendar so for me
that's more effective than a list
because it gives me the constraint of
time i know if i have a 10-minute task
or 20-minute test i can place all those
in my calendar and then i get
competitive against myself in terms of
like the actual routine of the day i
wake up between four and five i go to
bed between eight and ten 10 at the
latest and i start working i have lunch
in the middle of the day which gets
delivered to my door which is a jersey
mic sub at this point i work again and
then we go out to dinner and then about
every other day i work out in the middle
of the day because i run a split shift
so basically i work i work out that
gives me a little bit of a boost and
then i do a second half and that's
pretty much how i live